you know the afghan friends that i've
come to be close with really love i mean
the
the humor there's so much there i have
common common stuff of like
when i go to ireland it's one of my
favorite places and just like the
i feel a sense of pressure like the
humor all around me all the time i feel
like there's something between iron like
i learned in russia
with the humor stuff
where it's like you've you got to be on
your game if you want to be you know so
it's
yeah it's not i feel like i mean the
intensity of conversation
in terms of yeah you have to be on your
game in terms of wit and so on i mean
you have to
there's certain people i have like when
i talked on this podcast they're like
that uh certain people from the jewish
tradition have that totally like where
the where is just like okay i have to
oh yeah i really have to pay attention
yeah yeah it's a game it's like it's
like uh you know what it feels like it
feels like speed chess or something like
that and you really have to
focus and play and at the same time
there's body language in the and then
there's a melancholy nature to it at
least in the russian side yeah the whole
thing is just a beautiful moment yeah
there's a there's a funny two-top video
that went around it that i got from like
some afghan acquaintances that was a
he's an irish comedian
kind of
highlighting you know kind of irish and
german natural stereotypes around
hospitality
and um this afghan woman said you know i
didn't know that the
irish were just white afghans because
the whole like the hospitality like
politics of like of refusal you know you
you know you don't you don't take
something that's offered to the first
time you don't i mean it's the
the culture of um
of receiving a guest you know that's you
know
americans aren't i mean that's not you
know that's not always i mean they're
different the regional cultures where
that's the thing there's whatever but
it's i mean the
the kind of like generosity and the kind
of you know that that's that's real i
mean that's
and that's a cool thing and that's
amazing that's um you know the food i
mean going on just the sufficient things
but with the
but all that the the warmth of
hospitality and um
wit and and humanity i mean it's
that that that's what we don't see
viewing the place just through war and
geopolitics and the moving pieces of the
map and stuff and that's
and that's hard to see when you know
there are gaps in language and in
religious tradition and all that stuff
and then
you know being open the fact that people
do
do things differently you know it's uh
and the gender did mention there's
important right they're they're kind of
you know
arguably each culture has a kind of
gender dynamic that's different and so i
think it's helpful to have humility in
thinking that
some afghans will do something something
different differently you know but then
you'll also have afghans who say
every woman should be educated everyone
should work and so on and so on so
there's no there's no single way of yeah
and there is a dynamic in russia too we
need to be respectful that like
that's not that's not always what it
looks like at first yeah exactly there's
layers where power is i mean that's
definitely i don't know yeah uh yeah
that's a whole nother conversation where
the power is
you